is charlize theron thinking about having
more kids oh god I stop we're funny I
think I have my hand both of my hands
are really full right now I think I'm
good for now
what's your two threes no I mean
literally my son's like let's get a cat
and I'm like no no no more things that
need to be fed we're slowing down
okay maybe not anytime soon but the
huntsmen star did gush about the two she
has when we caught up with her at the
film's premiere there's not one moment
where I don't know where I don't realize
how unbelievably lucky I have and how
just they're just their little gems they
really are they're just they're yeah
they're amazing
she adorably thanked them in her
acceptance speech at the MTV Movie
Awards for her role in Mad Max fury road
there was no way I couldn't thank my son
cuz it was a tough movie for me to make
and he was in the trailer every single
day and it was like you know on those
days that were really tough he's so
disarming and you kind of come into the
trailer and he just makes you smile and
he makes everything feels like you know
you just know what the perspective is
but as sweet as Charlize is in person
she's taking on a villainous role in
fast and furious 8 it's super exciting I
am so I I mean honestly it's it's like
being invited to the coolest family
party high school dance possible what
will you do crazy to be a villain will
you will you shave your head will you do
what are you gonna do see now it's like
you know I'm gonna have to like do
something really extreme like once once
you're like I don't I don't know it's
very early where we had a big meeting
today we're gonna like you know
definitely try and do something cool
because the movie deserves that and you
know come up with something that is just
right for the film
you